nous sommes ici à la cuisine centrale du
port restaurant qui desservent un
établissement dont serait ce qu'aux
riches qui ont fait le tour on commence
par le collège site en lui-même là où
nous sommes on descend un petit peu on a
le collège ves le collège albius ou est
incluse comme cité scolaire nancy le
lycée lepervanche de dans le collège
oasis on descend toujours pas sur la
possession on a le lycée de la
possession de lycées albanie le collège
teixeira en décembre un petit peu plus
on a le collège de tous les symboles
collège des temps et le collège sougou
inclut le lycée louis payen chaque jour
tous ces établissements scolaires ou
choix entre trois entrées trois plats et
trois desserts qui sont élaborées ici
par l'équipe qui travaille au tt de
notre chef de cuisine
aujourd'hui au menu voilà ça va te
proposait notamment une salade russe qui
a une salade piémontaise
et bien ça va tenir en place on va droit
de l'omelette un carry back from de
terre insos sardines en accompagnement
un riverain rigail éventuellement des
pommes sautées cbf a été livrée hier
matin comme on travaille en entrée nous
parce qu'on ait marché interne avec un
futur pays donc libre et il ya matin
cuisiner ce matin et meilleur acteur
pour être consommés ce jeudi midi un
cari de boeuf dessiné à 3000 personnes
et qui a nécessité pour sa préparation
450 kg de boeuf pays et frêle il prépare
un logis de la place la veille mais 52
kg tomates et d'oignons en préparation à
l'ordre du jour un grappin de
citrouilles des dizaines de kilos de
citrouilles pays agrémenté de sauce
béchamel de fromage et de panure qui
seront cuits immédiatement dans les
fours de la crise
une vingtaine partager avec trois
chauffeurs 3 au magasin
une équipe la légumerie une hotte
au dressage des plats et il nous reste à
le pré 6 à faire la cuisine et des
fruits et légumes issus de l'agriculture
locale
une ambition que se donnent les cuisines
centrales de pouvoir se fournir en
produits pays essentiellement le seul
petit souci c'est de temps en temps on
n'a pas de légumes pays
quand j'étais légumes pays on a
quasiment presque tous les légumes sorte
de carotte attend encore madeleine
une vingtaine de personnes travaillent à
la cuisine centrale de titan au port de
ces locaux ce sont des milliers de repas
qui sortent chaque jour et le menu de
fête annonce toutes ses promesses civet
de cerf et carys camaro et collégiens et
les autres élèves l'attendent sûrement
avec impatience